WITH SENATOR CLAIRE McCASKILL
ON THE SHOW LATER.
FIRST THERE IS A NEW OPERATION
UNDERWAY AT THIS HOUR TO KEEP
SEVERAL CARAVANS OF MIGRANTS
FROM ENTERING THE U.S.
AFTER AN ORDER FROM THE
PRESIDENT, PENTAGON OFFICIALS
SAY MORE THAN 5,000 TROOPS ARE
BEING SENT TO THE U.S. SOUTHERN
BORDER, WITH HUNDREDS ARRIVING
TODAY.
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION WEIGHS
ITS OPTIONS FOR STOPPING THE
FLOW OF ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS WITH
AN EXECUTIVE ORDER.
A PRESIDENT TRUMP WILL DISCUSS
THE IMMIGRATION FIGHT IN AN
INTERVIEW ON FOX NEWS AT
10:00 P.M. TONIGHT WITH
LAURA INGRAHAM.
THEY WILL BE DISCUSSING THE
HORRIFIC KILLING OF 11 PEOPLE AT
A PITTSBURGH SYNAGOGUE OVER THE
WEEKEND.
CHIEF WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENT
JOHN ROBERTS IS ON THE NORTH
LAWN WITH A LOOK AT HOW THE
ADMINISTRATION IS HANDLING ALL
OF IT TONIGHT.
GOOD EVENING, JOHN.
>> THE NATIONAL GUARD HAS BEEN
SENT TO THE BORDER MANY TIMES TO
ASSIST THE BORDER PATROL, BUT
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS MAKING AN
EVEN GREATER SHOW OF FORCE,
DISPATCHING 5200 ACTIVE DUTY
MILITARY TO THE BORDER.
IN AN EXTRAORDINARY MOVE, THE
PENTAGON WILL BE SENDING FORCES,
MANY OF THEM ACTIVE DUTY, TO THE
BORDER WITH MEXICO.
IN AN EXCLUSIVE INTERVIEW WITH
LAURA INGRAHAM TERRA 10:00 P.M.
TONIGHT, PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID
THE MILITARY DEPLOYMENT IS TO
KEEP THE CARAVANS NUMBERING
THREE FROM CROSSING THE BORDER
AND END THE PRACTICE OF CATCH
AND RELEASE.
>> WE ARE GOING TO HAVE TENTS.
THEY ARE GOING TO BE VERY NICE.
THEY'RE GOING TO WAIT.
IF THEY DON'T GET A SILENT THEY
GET OUT.
IF YOU WANT TO WAIT, THEY DON'T
USUALLY GET ASYLUM.
>> THE DEPLOYMENT, DUBBED
OPERATION FAITHFUL PATRIOT WILL
PUT 5200 TROOPS AT THE BORDER.
MILITARY POLICE, ENGINEERS,
DOCTORS, AVIATION ASSETS TO
SUPPORT CUSTOMS AND BORDER
PROTECTION PERSONNEL.
>> OUR MESSAGE THE ORGANIZERS
AND PARTICIPANTS IN THE CARAVAN
IS SIMPLE.
WE WILL NOT ALLOW A LARGE GROUP
TANGIBLE THE UNITED STATES IN AN
UNSAFE AND UNLAWFUL MANNER.
>> THE WHITE HOUSE IS
CONSIDERING EXECUTIVE OR
REGULATORY ACTION.
ONE IDEA BEING KICKED AROUND,
ONLY ALLOW MIGRANTS TO MAKE
ASYLUM CLAIMS AT PORTS OF ENTRY.
MEANING MIGRANTS WHO CROSS THE
BORDER ILLEGALLY WOULD NOT BE
ALLOWED TO CLAIM ASYLUM IN THE
UNITED STATES.
>> THERE ARE A LOT OF OPTIONS
THAT ARE BEING DISCUSSED RIGHT
NOW.
THE NUMBER ONE PRIORITY IS
LOOKING FOR WAYS TO SECURE OUR
BORDERS.
>> THE HORRIFIC SHOOTING AT THE
TREE OF LIFE SYNAGOGUE WAS ALSO
ON THE WHITE HOUSE AGENDA TODAY.
PRESS SECRETARY SARAH SANDERS
BECOMING VISIBLY EMOTIONAL AT
TIMES.
>> THIS ATROCITY WAS A CHILLING
ACT OF MASS MURDER, AN ACT OF
HATRED AND ABOVE ALL IT WAS AN
ACT OF EVIL.
SPEAK WITH THE PRESIDENT ALSO
TOOK ON HIS FAVORITE FOIL, THE
NEWS MEDIA, TWEETING:
"THERE IS GREAT ANGER IN OUR
COUNTRY CAUSED IN PART BY
INACCURATE, AND EVEN FRAUDULENT,
REPORTING OF THE NEWS.
THE FAKE NEWS MEDIA, THE TRUE
ENEMY OF THE PEOPLE, MUST STOP
THE OPEN AND OBVIOUS HOSTILITY
AND REPORT THE NEWS ACCURATELY
AND FAIRLY."
WHILE THERE IS NOTHING TO
SUGGEST THE SYNAGOGUE KILLERS
HATRED WAS MOTIVATED BY THE
MEDIA, PRESIDENT TRUMP SAYS HIS
TWEETS WERE JUSTIFIED.
>> I WAS IN THE HEADLINE WHEN
THEY GOT HIM.
THEY DIDN'T SAY FARMER FOUND.
THEY TALKED ABOUT TRUMPING THE
HEADLINE.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP WILL TRAVEL
TO PITTSBURGH TOMORROW WHAT HE
HOPES WILL BE A MOMENT OF
NATIONAL UNITY.
11 JEWISH LEADERS FROM THE AREA
OF SAID THE PRESIDENT IS NOT
WELCOME UNLESS AND UNTIL HE
FULLY DENOUNCES WHITE
NATIONALISM.
>> DOES THE WHITE HOUSE BELIEVE
THIS PRESIDENT HAS DONE ENOUGH
TO DENOUNCE WHITE NATIONALISM?
>> THE PRESIDENT HATRED AND
BIGOTRY ON ALL FORMS.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP SAYS HE WILL
VISIT PITTSBURGH TOMORROW TO PAY
IS RESPECT TO THE 11 PEOPLE
KILLED.
HE SAID HE WILL VISIT A HOSPITAL
-- MEET WITH THE VICTIMS OF THE